The first movie that made a big impression on me was Princess Bride.
"My name is Inigo Montoya."
"You killed my father."
"Prepare to die."
I think that "The Never-ending Story" was the first movie crush that I had.
Atreyu was his name?
He was the boy from the book, the warrior...
...and I just remember watching this movie for like, 20 times.
I had a thing for boys with long hair when I was nine.
I was 18, I just graduated high school...
...and I had some time in between going to the army.
My mom figured, "Hey, why don't I send your photo?"
"You finished school and this is like, proper pageant."
Whatever.
I got in and I never thought I would win.
And then I won, and then it scared me.
I was like, "What? Miss Israel? All the responsibility of being Miss Israel."
But did you go to Miss Universe as Miss Israel?
Yes, and I was very naughty.
I was very, I wasn't behaving.
I'm a really good girl but because I was afraid I'm gonna win again,...
...because I didn't want to win the Miss Israel pageant and then I won,...
...I figured, "Oh no, I don't want them to choose me again."
So, I came down late to all the rehearsals...
...and I wasn't wearing the right evening gowns for breakfast.
I even remember Paula Abdul, she was one of the judges there...
...and she was asking me a question and I was like, "I'm sorry, English not so good,"...
...because I just didn't wanna have anything to do with that.